[Music]
event thread detection etd
is a built-in service in security
command center premium it uses log data
from google cloud audit logs
cloud networking logs and operating
system logs when a thread is detected
etd writes a finding to cloud scc and to
a logging project
event thread detection analyzes cloud
audit logs vpc flow logs
cloud firewall logs cloud nat logs dns
logs and linux syslogs to find threats
etd works best when vpc flow logging and
cloud dns logging are active
event threat detection is automatically
enabled when you subscribe to security
command center premium
if you need to re-enable etd first make
sure you have a security command center
admin
and security center sources admin iam
roles along with an sec premium
subscription
on the sec home page go to the sources
and services settings page
then click the toggle next to event
threat detection to enable it
click save then under the resources tab
select the scope for etd we recommend
enabling it at the org node level and
allowing the rest of the org to inherit
the on
setting etd can quickly detect a number
of potential high risk and costly
threats
brute force ssh etd detects successful
brute force of ssh on a host
by examining linux auth logs for
repeated failures followed by a
successful login
crypto mining etd detects coin mining
malware by examining vpc logs for
connections to
or up of a known mining domain or ip
address
cloud iam abuse malicious grants atd
detects privileges granted to identity
and access management users and service
accounts that are not members of the
organization
malware atd detects malware based on a
connection to
or lookup of a known bad domain or ip
address by examining vpc logs for
connections to known bad domains and
other log data
phishing etd examines vpc logs for
suspicious connections and other log
data
outgoing denial of service etd detects
outgoing denial of service traffic by
examining the sizes types and numbers of
vpc flow logs
data exfiltration from bigquery etd
detects when data is leaving a table
owned by your organization
or when a copy is attempted that is
blocked by a vpc service control
you can learn more about these findings
in the documentation linked below
you can view findings in cloud logging
if you configured scc syncs to write
logs to the google cloud operations
suite
or in the scc findings tab filter by
source type and select event threat
detection
in our environment we can see our top
findings let's drill into the malware
bad ip finding we're able to see what
the event was
when the event occurred the source of
the finding data
and the detection severity under source
properties we can find additional
evidence
drilling into the evidence we can find
out the log id
project time stamps and insert id
we can also see the affected resources
and under properties
we can even see the source ip port
destination ip and
instance details to display all findings
that were affected by this source ip
we can apply a filter in the findings
tab filter box
enter source properties properties ips
and paste the source ip security command
center displays all of the findings that
are associated with
event findings affected by this source
ip next we can continue to pivot on
either this ip
or the project in the filter bar to do
further detections and create firewall
rules blocking access from this ip
congratulations you've enabled event
threat detection and learn how to
respond to a finding from it
[Music]
you